hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another
code review for those of you not
familiar with this series this is where
i basically take a look at your code and
try and give suggestions
and or thoughts depending on what the
project is if you would like the
opportunity to appear on the next
episode of the code review series then
read the description there'll be some
information as well as an email address
where you can send your code
to so today i thought we would do
something a little bit different for
this series in the past we've been
looking at
like graphical projects mostly stuff
that we can look at on the screen
whether that be like a 2d
game engine or a game or some kind of
like particle demo that's what we looked
at
last time i'll have that video linked up
there but i know a lot of you watching
my videos are just students and maybe
it's even your first or second year of
university
you're going through and learning about
all these different data structures so
what i have today
is an actual real world university
assignment where the task was to write a
hashmap
this particular person who sent in this
code wishes to remain anonymous probably
because this actually was a university
assignment and maybe there are
certain rules against sharing them but
for the purposes of this we'll call him
tim that may or may not be his real name
so tim has sent in
a single file implementation of this as
about 200 lines of code here as well as
the actual university assignment sheet
which is really cool because
i'll actually see what the requirements
are i think that it's worth noting that
with these university assignments i mean
i remember
the ones that i kind of got some of them
had weird requirements and the marking
criteria was also
not really what i expected if you
contrast that with real world code like
if i was actually writing a hashmap for
my own purposes
it would probably be vastly different
than code that's specifically written
for a university assignment
so it's going to be really interesting
to actually take a look at a university
assignment but before we jump in i just
want to mention that this video is
sponsored by
skillshare for those of you who don't
know skillshare is an amazing online
learning community where millions of
creative and curious people from all
around the world come together
to learn new skills basically it's a
platform with concise
informative high quality classes that
will teach you almost
anything you want to learn whether you
are interested in photography
videography
more business side topics like business
management productivity marketing or one
of my personal favorites illustration
skillshare has you covered i've
mentioned this before but i think that
their illustration classes some of the
illustration classes that they have
there
are absolutely phenomenal and it's just
so relaxing to chill out after a long
work day and just draw something that's
one of my favorite things
to do right now coming in at just under
10 a month for an annual subscription
skillshare is also fantastic value i
honestly don't think there is any other
platform out there that has so much
information condensed into such a
consumable format a lot of their classes
have videos that are like 5 to 10
minutes long which is perfect if you
only have a spare moment
but for a limited time skillshare is
giving the first 1000 people who click
the link in the description below
a free trial of skillshare premium so
that you can access
their whole library for free and see
what they have i highly recommend you do
that you will not be disappointed
huge thank you to skillshare as always
for sponsoring this video let's take a
look at some of this code
i think it's amazing that you have to
submit this
via svn so before we jump into the code
that is in front of us and take a look
i've been reading this assignment sheet
i don't really want to show it because
it gives like the name of the university
there's a bunch of stuff here you know
we'll just ignore this you guys will
just have to take my word for it but
this is like what an assignment this is
i mean
i don't know who wrote this it's just
very strange
like it's it's odd to me because i feel
like the assignment could have been
you know just write a hash map that
works maybe like
four strings hashes strings you know
generates like a little index
as to where to store your data and then
like let us be able to
retrieve this and maybe basically avoid
some you know collisions in most cases
with the test data
like that would be a reasonable
assignment this
is very interesting and i think it's
almost more fun that you guys don't know
what i'm seeing because as we look
through this code
i think it's going to be quite amazing
anyway so first of all there's a
disclaimer here which i think is great
assignment requirements set by the hash
table size uh set the hash table size of
26. i have
verified that is in fact the case which
is also the maximum amount of entries
i know this is bad for two reasons once
it's not prime preferred size of the
table is 26 times 1.3 to minimize the
chance of collisions
sure however this is assignment
requirements yes some of these
assignment requirements are a bit weird
let's um so this is all the code that we
have here let's maybe start with the
main function
because that's a good place to start
reading code from i think so the first
thing we do is create a string
called str now this is already a you
know i'm going to start the critique
here um don't do this
like name the variables so what is str
i mean you know i can maybe deduce the
str
is going into you know get line c in so
this is us taking input from the console
so like maybe something like you know at
least input or like
um you know input string or like you
know
whatever something a little bit more
destructive descriptive than
str because that's a little bit annoying
like this is called user input
but this you know i'm not the biggest
fan of this okay good so we get the line
from cn
sure then we send it into the input
formatter function which is all the way
up here
um this takes the string this copies the
string um
and then i guess has an output
of user input now one thing i personally
like doing you don't really need to do
this
if you don't want to but i like well
first of all i like writing the um
you know the uh the asterisk or the
uh reference the ampersand reference
operator on this side i know some people
prefer it on this and there are reasons
for both
but um that's besides the point my point
is that user input is clearly meant to
be an output
right this is where this data is being
pushed to
so what i would do is just name it
something like out user input that just
makes a little bit more sense
as to like what's going on with user
input especially if the variable is
called input
because that almost implies that maybe
this returns something but it doesn't
that's also an option you know return uh
you know in this case we're creating a
um
are we using this function a lot
actually no we've nev we never use it
again
so this would be a good example of maybe
having that vector be a return value
because then
these two lines and all of this kind of
code would just be simplified to
hey you know let's take in the string
and then let's format it into this
vector of strings so that might be a
little bit easier
to understand which is always good um by
the way with these like code reviews i
mean even right now i'm just looking at
this code and i'm going to give
some uh advice as to how maybe to write
the code better like the thing is
the the the requirements for this
assignment are set in stone and they are
pretty not flexible um and i think my
favorite part of the requirements was
also how it says
that this will marking will be done
automatically the total mark is 10 one
for compiling
so i guess if it compiles you get one
mark and nine for nine test cases
i don't know if it it doesn't outline
the actual test case but it gives you
some
sample input inputs and kind of expected
outputs
but in general the requirements are very
specific i think that if anything
this is maybe teaching how to follow
requirements
because uh again they're just very non
like
real world use case kind of requirements
anyway so what do we do here
so we go through the size of the string
which again is the input now the first
thing i would do
here by the way is definitely not take
this string in as a copy like this like
that definitely doesn't need to be done
now this is an existing string you
basically have two options
you can take it in as a const reference
that's probably what i would
do because i tend to do that a lot the
other thing you could do is just use a
string
view that's just basically a view into
that string that just
it doesn't copy it it just it's almost
like passing a pointer to the string
data
with like an end point as well so that
will just make it a little bit better
because you won't have to actually copy
that string which of course is a little
bit of a waste of time
not that this is a performance issue
it's absolutely not we run this once at
the start of our program no one's even
going to notice that
but for future use that that's i think
that's helpful advice
going through every character in the
string is our next case
and if the string character does not
equal 32
okay please don't do this
just write code like this right
so 32 is the ascii uh
value 32 in decimal is the ascii value
for a space
um this code is already a lot more
readable i mean
who on earth understands that 32 is a
thing um
so yeah write code like that it's going
to be better
one thing i noticed with a lot of this
code that actually people send me
is just the formatting is just bad like
for example you know we have a new line
for this and for this for these braces
but then this one just
is is on the same line for some reason
this one's on a new line but that's on
the same line it's a little bit
inconsistent
so if you're not using like visual
studio or like
an ide with an auto formatter just
because i know visual studio will try
and clean this
stuff up for you whereas other tools
will actually um have you like
run i guess a command or something to
make it happen
just you know maybe just just clean it
up and make sure it looks good
again this does not affect the
apparently this is does not affect the
result of the assignment because it's
marked automatically by a computer
i would imagine and um if it can if it
compiles and
succeeds with the nine test cases that's
a hundred percent so
why bother i guess but i would still do
that
and removing like all these comments
which again does not affect the
assignment grade so it's
i'm not digging this assignment um so
yeah i would basically format things
like this
okay so if it's not a space we basically
have a temp string that we append to
okay this is bad for a number of reasons
um what i would do though is rewrite
this whole algorithm
with basically instead of actually
iterating through every character as if
this is like the stone age just use
some more modern kind of stl functions
and particularly string has something
called like
find which will actually try and look
for something like a space within the
string
don't remember the exact um like
signature of this function but what you
can do is actually recursively do that
until it's like until you've searched
the whole string and then just
take each because that will that will
return the position of the space
you can use that to basically uh
substring you know all of the other
string functions and create new strings
out of them which seems to be the
intended output of this function uh sub
string
so i would i would basically do that um
that would just be a little bit of a
better way to pass this
uh you know unless you want to like full
and create like a tokenizer
which i probably wouldn't um there's
also a c api that you can use i remember
using this back in the day
string string i guess i think that also
returns a pointer to a constituent array
that is at what you're looking for
something like that but basically
using the library a little bit more than
writing this by hand would just be
easier
and again the point of this assignment
is clearly not to do this all you're all
you're trying to do here is sort out
your input basically split string by
space
and simple doesn't have like a little
you know
string.split thing where you can just
split it by space and get an array back
like a lot of other languages do
so using something like find and
substring is probably your best bet
otherwise that's that function sorted um
by the way let me know what you guys
think about the level of detail i'm
going into with all these like should i
just
you know this isn't very big that's why
i'm doing this if it was like 100 files
obviously i couldn't
do that but uh anyway if this is um yeah
just let me know
all right so number number of inputs
user input.size
okay so this is an example of variables
that i think are useless
num input if this was called something
like completely different
then i would i would probably see some
worth as to creating like
a variable out of it so like number of
like
apples or something right from user
input does size
that adds so much meaning to what that
actually is
what this is num input you don't need
that variable because the variable is
here
right instead of using num input you
could just use this
um another reason to have num input is
if you changed it which you don't
right so if maybe if you were like going
to decrement it or something like that
then
of course you'd have to bring it on to a
variable but i would just skip that have
as little
as have have less variables unless
you know the the weight that you get
like the data you need is like a huge
string then maybe
you would want to simplify that into
like an alias using a reference
or bring it onto a variable like this
but otherwise i would just rewrite that
code like
that basically um okay and then we have
uh our hash table okay cool
so um hash map hash table by the way
same thing obviously
unordered map is also what um c plus
plus calls it
so let's look at the hash table class
which is
like three lines of code okay cool so
hash table um
it's a class that's good public status
object okay and then the constructor
sets
the status to never used now
i probably would have thought that this
was just a debugging thing
but actually it's like
it's in the assignment like you have to
set
a table slot has three different
statuses never used tombstone
and occupied the table starts with 26
never used slots
so this is all legit um just so you guys
know i just want to make that clear
um anyway so we create 26 of these all
right
all right so first of all
um we don't need to set this up like
this at all
um the first thing i want to say
actually if we go back to this
hash table class here right is that
you don't need a constructor you can
just set the status to never used up
here
right and then just not have a
constructor
the reason being that when it gets
initialized like this isn't like prior
to c
plus 11 when you couldn't have
assignments like this in like
header file well in header files and
like class declarations like this
um so we can definitely do that and that
will probably be better and it would
just reduce the amount the need for this
code this is also
useless because it's the same as just
calling the default constructor
um so i i would basically rewrite this
class to look something like this and
again because
it's a public bunch of members
i would also remove this and just make
it a structs
no difference between a structure or
class apart from the fact that structs
are public by default if you don't
specify something whereas classes are
essentially private by default they're
members i mean so
that's how i would rewrite this class
however at the very least what you could
have done
is just basically ran status with
never used like this in kind of the
constructor i guess initializer list
the reason being that um that prevents
the string from being created twice
once up here again it's an empty string
this point is not
about like performance it's just more
about like code style and what actually
is happening so that you're more aware
um you know in this case it creates a
string up here
um and then also it would have it would
have created it down here again
reassigned it
to something else and constructed a
string out of this kind of
char const chart pointer essentially
using an implicit constructor
again so you've kind of made two strings
whereas if you if you write one of these
bad boys it basically
replaces whatever you wrote here so this
is now meaningless it will instead use
this
um so that's kind of important but again
you know
in this case i would not do anything
like this by the way i don't know what
version of c plus plus
this needs to compile with um i think it
it actually did mention
okay yeah c plus 11 with optimization
level two
using g plus plus that is what's going
on here okay cool
interesting um so yeah sables 11
definitely supports everything that i'm
doing so this is how i would rewrite
this basically
um and just get rid of that because you
don't need it uh okay so
okay we create 26 of these now this is
the other thing um you could create like
this you could just use an array as well
so we could have an array of like hash
table objects like this
26 of them this is what i would do again
the reason being that we now have site
the biggest reason honestly for this is
that apart from having some nice
functions
uh to help us out with certain things we
have a size right a size that isn't
really stored as a variable
um but that we can retrieve using an api
like this that's a lot better than
having to
use the value 26 you know here for
example
you would just write something like
array
array of object.size and that would be
that
speaking of which you actually don't
need this for loop whatsoever
there are a few ways to actually fill an
array you could use something like std
fill but i would instead use this
so if you just do that or assign it to
essentially an empty set of parentheses
or
curly brackets rather like this then
it's actually going to
initialize all of the objects with um
you know whatever value you set there
which is nothing meaning that the
default constructor will be called for
all
26 of these objects meaning that you
don't need this for loop like
whatsoever so you could just completely
remove that
i'm gonna by the way keep the original
code if you guys want to see like a
video of me completely rewriting this
entire assignment the way i would write
it let me know in the comments below
but obviously i'm trying to do a code
review here and not rewrite everything
so i'm gonna probably stop doing this in
the future
for this video i mean but basically yeah
do something like this and it means that
you don't need any of this
in this case this is used for just
initializing all the elements but if you
had something a little bit more simple
like maybe
you know five integers you could also
use this to essentially give a value for
each of the integers
so initialize the lists are great okay
anyway moving on so we've chosen to go
with this which is fine and then that
means that yeah essentially we do need
to initialize it using an algorithm like
this
or an algorithm a for loop like this
okay and then we go through the user
input dot size so this is now the
kind of um separated by spaces
uh tokenized kind of commands i guess
that we've given in the user input
so what are the commands that we can
handle so we have this function called
command get now
again you know this is a very
interesting
uh code style right like literally
every single every single style
has been used here in terms of like in
terms of function names
like i mean literally like we have this
i don't even know what this one's called
this kind of snake case but then with
the
capital second word letter like get
we have this kind of i think pascal case
is what it's called
um it's very like microsoft style uh
we've got this one which again could be
i guess
snake case um then we've got this one
which is
uh camel case um
we've got we've got them all we've we've
got them all input formatter
is another example of pascal case so um
i don't know why
just stick to one and just use it um
very important
uh because
see the thing is i can't even give this
advice because you still get a hundred
percent
if you get this anyway whatever okay it
doesn't matter
we'll move on we'll move on from that so
command get user input i
okay so we give it a character a single
character no no sorry
user input is a vector so we give it a
string essentially so this is probably
also by
oh no no this is by reference okay
that's better i guess it's going to
actually
write out to that string yeah it resizes
the string so what does this do
so we get the first character um
we then uh resize this string oh so you
are using substring so you're aware of
that which is good
we get the first character we we
basically use this temp string thing
here to just resize this to be one
um or not resize it but to basically um
select uh you know ever the entire
string
minus the first character basically so
we drop the first character from the
string and assign it to temp string
then we resize the string
and then we reassign it which is defeats
the purpose of
resizing it here for no reason okay this
is all very messy
um this is what you need this is what
you're trying to do i think
i think you're just trying to do this
without any of this
you're just trying to take the string
and reassign it to basically a substring
of that original string
that doesn't include the first character
so we can just leave it at that and not
and not get too crazy
and then we return the very first
character so we've saved out the first
character into a variable because that
we're
changing it we're changing what the
string is we're dropping that first
character and that's what we return
seems weird right well actually it's
because the assignment says that
the way that we give commands to this
program is we basically have to have the
first character specified as
either a or d in which case a means that
we
add to the hashmap and then d means we
delete so in other words
an example command might be like i want
to add cherno to the hashmap
and then i want to delete cherno from
the hashmap that's literally what this
literally what you do
you just do this um so that's why we're
looking at that first character
and then kind of separating it because
obviously this is the actual value we
want to add but then this is what says
what to do so
again a very creative assignment
um so what do we do okay so basically
what this is the switch case is now
operating on that very first character
whereas the user input has now been
modified
to contain not the first character so
we've kind of trimmed that off
we just have the key i guess that we're
actually trying to add
to the map um which begs the question is
it really a map if all we're doing is
adding keys without
values um this is more of like a hash
set
to be honest uh at this point in time so
um but i guess maybe we are storing some
kind of associated
anyway let's not jump the gun let's see
what's let's see what's happening so the
first thing we do if we want to add
something
is we search so remember array of
objects is that
that hash table array which hash table
really is just
two strings um object which i guess
stores the actual value
and then status which is a string that
is initialized with never used
so then we go through this um we search
we okay so let's let's let's go through
this first of all so we take the actual
string so like churner let's just
we'll leave this up here so that it's
clear what the command was a cherno
so now we know that this user input
contains just cherno
we put it into the hash function so the
hash function sees
cherno what's our hash function i think
this is a bad function because words
ending in the same letter will end up
being placed in the same slot in the
hash table
why yes that does sound bad but i also
don't know how to write a better
function using only the one
character so i will keep going
only the one character yes because i
think i remember something in the
assignment
talking about how you're only allowed to
use a single character to generate a
unique
hash what is happening anyway
whatever um so what do we do here we we
do
char get string what what does that
function do
it returns the last character in the
string
and and of course it has time to copy
the string okay
so first things first don't do this
you can just you know do something like
string
i don't know string size minus one here
right doesn't need to be a function
and instead of calling this chi which is
almost
you know the beginning of a good word
you could instead actually call this
something like last character
that immediately makes this algorithm or
this hash
function way more readable
right so then we do in constant and then
we do oh look you know how to use these
things
in like mathematical operations so
definitely then
you should have done the space where was
it
um this is also not very well organized
but we won't get into that too much
um in the uh
in here right you should have have done
that
okay back to the hash function so in
constant equals
so the last character then we subtract
uh the ascii value of
zero which i i i would say i know what
that is but i'd be lying
um so let me just get back my ascii
table so
0 is in fact 48 so that's kind of like
the start of i guess the usable
characters
because um anything below that is a
symbol like divided by or comma or plus
and then anything above that we
basically well i mean we have our
numbers then we have like colon
semicolon stuff like that and then we
have capital
uh letters and then log case letters so
um that's kind of like i guess the
this is almost like our zero um and then
we subtract so basically any character
any character really is guaranteed to be
above zero most likely unless we we're
giving it like
a character that we shouldn't be maybe
like as far as this
assignment goes um we add three to it
which is a bit weird so we get
kind of the value from that start we get
three get three and then we mod it by 26
and that that is that is what our our
index i guess is or like at least our
hash function
very interesting um and again it's just
taking that last character
so this obviously only really functions
on the last character
now the fact that this is already mod 26
and 26 happens to be the size
means that this probably actually you
know this isn't just the hash function
that generates a hash for us
it actually specifies what bucket that
we should be storing our value in or
retrieving our value from so this
actually gives us back that index
so hash maps um hash maps obviously uh
store all of their values in various
buckets and you the hash function
the point of the hash function is to
generate a value that can then be used
to actually get an
index and then you can see where your
data should be or is
so that's what this is doing so it's
kind of doing two in one here okay cool
so that's our hash function
so now we basically get back an index as
to where to store our data
that's the point that's our data and
that's my array
so search is doing that um so i guess
the thing is we're already specifying
something so it's not like we're
searching by string
so what exactly does this search
function does
do what exactly does this search
function does okay
so we're taking an array um sure i'll
probably write this a little bit
differently i think this is kind of old
school
not that it's a huge uh you know
difference in this case and we have a
place here
so we actually okay so we basically
check to see if this is almost like a
little collision
check um we check to see if the array
contains an object that has the same
name as the one we're trying to insert i
guess um and if sober return negative
one
uh otherwise if the status is never used
so obviously this
it doesn't equal now so it's either
never used or it's occupied never used
of course being this uh
you know status here very important that
you spell that right and don't use
capital
or lowercase um you know letters
accidentally or something like that or
write it as one word because otherwise
the whole algorithm breaks so yeah
extremely important
to uh you know when you're dealing with
strings as statuses for some reason but
again
assignment requirements value cannot be
used in the hash table this object
doesn't exist so i think i think it
means
can be used in the hash table maybe
because this obviously means that it's
free
um otherwise if it's occupied we try and
basically resolve that
collision i guess by just like doing
something like this um
again what you could do is uh
you know not do this but use that
beautiful modulus operator you
you were using earlier to just basically
make it so that you do something like
you know place plus one mod 26 maybe
like that
and then that's kind of just a little
bit of a better way to write that
a little bit of code so you don't need
the if statement
um and then we basically recursively try
and see
like okay well let's increment the the
index
and then see if that's free so a little
bit of collision
kind of avoidance i guess but uh this is
also slightly dangerous because if they
are all occupied
this will just crash with the stack
overflow exception because you
you never stop searching and if you've
exhausted all 26 slots that's the end of
the day that
that's the end so um let's not do it
that way
but anyway if this doesn't return
negative one then obviously we're good
we have an index for it so now we do
search for free so there's a lot of
stuff going on here that seemingly
shouldn't be happening like why what
we've searched already we know that it's
free
why are we searching again um not sure
but anyway
this basically does the same thing this
this actually looks
almost the same as the other function
but um
i i mean i don't know again recursively
looks for
recursively tries to like increment the
index search for a new kind of place if
there's a collision
um otherwise if it's never used or as a
tombstone meaning i guess
the object has been deleted it used to
be there but has been deleted then we
get that index back so
yeah not sure i mean ideally again into
an empty hash table
into an empty hash table in this program
you would just immediately get your
place so i don't i don't know why this
is happening
and in fact it doesn't search return it
does return an integer
so um i mean this has nothing to do with
the whole tombstone situation
so what you can do is basically do
either never used
or tombstone right and in that case if
it's never used or tombstone then
obviously you can use that slot
and then basically just do something
like in play sql search up here
and then well that's it you don't need
that other function you can just go
ahead and add it
so i would um do something like that
okay anyway um so now we have the index
yet again i wouldn't call it place
either i'd call it index
sounds a bit more professional i guess
and a bit more
descriptive but i guess i guess they
mean the same thing right at the end at
the end of the day don't they
um and then add so what does add do it
changes the status and just
copies the object copies the string into
there again no reason to do something
like this
you know just do that or at the very
least if you're going to move this in
then maybe you could
you know move it in um yeah this is
beyond the assignment and i don't really
care
so let's move on huh move on so we break
which is good
um and then that's how we add objects
basically pretty straightforward how do
we delete
objects so we have again the search
function which
um now this is interesting right so okay
all right okay yeah so we need to make
sure that we find whether or not that
object exists
and then we find the place of it
actually hang on am i misunderstanding
something
so what does this do so search looks for
something
and then if it is occupied
it all right well negative one just
means it can't it can't find no no
negative one means it's founded
so in that case it doesn't give us a
place
yeah okay no so it's fine my thing still
works because if it's negative one
means it means like it it i guess it
already exists then it does nothing
because
this wouldn't be true so actually like
to be fair when i
wrote my thing um you know i should have
surrounded it with more parentheses so
that we actually check the
that variable then with um negative one
otherwise that wouldn't really work
but anyway um so yeah so we do the same
thing here we basically
this is just us checking to make sure
that it exists in the
in the hash table if it doesn't we can't
delete it right it's not there
so if it does exist we again search for
it
um because search returns negative one
if it exists um which means that we
don't get the index of
of where it exists it'd be nice to have
that as an output variable if you had
done something like that
you know how like a little out index or
whatever if it does in fact
find it if the function itself doesn't
return the index um which also wouldn't
have been a
bad idea we're trying to search for
something and we get an index but anyway
um so now we do search for kill
a nicely named function and this
basically um
i guess if it finds the string and the
status is not
tombstone then we found it and it's not
dead so we can
kill it i guess um otherwise if it's
occupied
i don't understand why this happens like
surely this is just us trying to find
the objects
that we now need to delete so
and then we're trying to find the index
of it so why would we recursively try
and
oh no hang on
i see okay yeah this this has to exist
because
if we previously had a collision
then we shifted it so it's possible
that even though the hash function says
that
you're at index 5 you may have actually
been at like index 7
because when you were inserted into the
hashmap it incremented your index twice
because there were collisions so that's
us doing the same thing here um yeah
what you need to do is cut
this three different search functions to
just a single search function
that just tells you the status
potentially
whether or not the object if the object
exists and you're trying to find that
the index of the found object
and then maybe like you know an empty
place or something like that again maybe
two functions one for like
add and one for actual search because
search again
search to me um you know it's kind of
like a find function
in which case you'd expect it to return
an existing object
right or nothing maybe negative one if
it couldn't find it at all
but this actually returns negative one
if it does find it so it's a little bit
a little bit weird anyway and then
finally we delete it so how do we do
that we pass in that array we pass in
the string by value again
and then we uh we have the index so we
basically do another check to see if
they're equal
um okay and then we set the status to
tombstone so we leave the data there
but we've just set it to tombstone
meaning it can be reused
cool um and that's kind of it so the
output is the
the good thing so basically we just go
through all 26
values here and we just see if the
status is occupied so if it's been
deleted it will be tombstone if it's
never used it'll be never used but if
it's occupied
that's good that means we basically
print it along with a space
which the assignment says is the
expected output and then we're
then we return zero so that is the um
hash table
assignment yeah wow that's um
this is uh i i have to say i
this is not at all what i expected okay
so i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to hit the
like button
as i mentioned earlier you can submit
your code to me for review by emailing
cherno review
gmail.com there will be that email
address in the description below as well
as some
instructions i hope that you guys have a
great rest of your day and don't forget
that you can check out skillshare for
free
by using the link in the description
below i'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you